what we're really doing of course is
some weird pan-dimensional trickery
because of course when we're working in
3d we add an a fourth dimension onto the
vectors and a fourth row and column onto
the matrices and we're doing a shear
operation in four dimensional space
which casts the shadow over of its
objects back into three-dimensional
space as a translation we chose in our
description before that the origin was
going to be here on the base of the
pyramid but in theory it could be
anywhere in the universe you can specify
the vertices relative to Mars or New
York or this point on the table over
here or the top of the pyramid or the
center or wherever the origin becomes
almost this like the center of gravity
of the object because any
transformations we do on the vertices
are done relative to the origin because
they're done in the same coordinate
space the same frame of reference that
the vertices are specified in so
transformations lots of transformations
that's a good question yeah we need to
we've specified our objects we specified
the vertices in the faces the way we
move objects around in 3d space is by
applying operations at the vertices
manipulating the vertices using
transformations what is a transformation
well there are three basic types of
transformation that we'll cover there
are others but the three basic types are
scaling translation and rotation and
we'll start with scaling I suppose so
ice trying and we'll keep it 2d for
simplicity sake so we want to scale our
triangle everything that's applicable to
in two dimensions it will also work in
three dimensions everything that we're
going to talk about it will work in
three dimensions for now let's just work
on scaling we want to scale it's a
vertically so the way we do that we'll
write out our coordinate let's just use
vertex a as an example now in
mathematics these coordinates are called
vectors vectors are just the raising
numbers basically I mean
everyone's familiar with the exes I like
to write them vertically you can write
them horizontally it doesn't really
matter but I think is probably more
clear if we write it vertically it's a
scalar vector we just need to do a
simple multiply operation so we want to
scale vertically so we don't want to
scale in X so we'll keep that as one but
we do want to scale in Y so we'll scale
by two and to get the answer all we do
is 0 times 1 is 0 1 times 2 is 2 and the
result if we apply flip this is our new
coordinate a it's up here at a equals 0
2 if we apply that same transformation
to our two vertices that are on the x
axis we find that they're unchanged
because minus 1 times 1 is 1
there's minus 1 and 0 times 2 is still 0
so those vertices still lie on y equals
0 translation works exactly the same
however instead of multiplying we add
here's our triangle that we started with
so say we now want to translate it one
unit this way well let's take this
coordinate as an example so we have one
in X and 0 in y plus we want to move one
unit in X so plus 1 unit in X and 0 and
y equals to 0 so this point now lies
over here and if we do that to all of
the vertices of our shape we get this so
we've had scaling and translation both
work very much the same one's a
multiplicative operation on vector or
vertex and the other is an additive
operation rotation is slightly more
complicated and involves trigonometry so
I'll just write out the formulas
trigonometry tells us that for any given
angle a our points X new X and new Y
somewhat convoluted but that's
trigonometry isn't it then let's take
our triangle again so this is our x-axis
is our y-axis we have our vertices as
before
let's take this point again and we want
to rotate it say by 90 degrees
anti-clockwise so we'll follow our
formula along here so our new x value is
going to be the x value here which is 1
0 because y is 0 these cancel out the
cosine of 90 is 0 the sine of 90 is 1 x
equals 0 y equals 1 so our new
coordinate is 0 1 which is what we'd
expect because we're rotating by 90
degrees so that covers scale translation
and rotation and by applying these
simple operations maybe not so simple in
the case of rotation we can move our
object around by manipulating the
vertices and we call these
transformations now there's actually if
we go back to rotation there's another
way to write out this formula that will
seem strange at first but bear with me
because the benefit of it will hopefully
become clearer we can draw a little
table I'll try and write a bit small
this time this basically represents
exactly the same information that we've
got here but just in a slightly
different format what we do is we
multiply our inputs down the columns and
then sum across the rows to get the
results so if we just take our example
that we had before of coordinates 1 0
wasn't incident so so our X is 1 and Y
is 0 so let's write our inputs in the
top here 1 x 0 x and the cosine of 90
which we want here is 0 and also the
cosine of 94 this part here is 0 minus
sine 90 is might as 1 and sine 90 is 1
so what did I say before we multiply
down the columns and then we sum across
the rows so 1 times
is zero 1 times 1 is 1
0 times minus 1 is 0 and 0 times 0 0 so
then we sum across the rows to get new X
and new y 0 plus 0 is 0 1 plus 0 is 1
which is the answer we got before this
representation of these formula here is
in mathematical terms called
and matrix matrices are very important
and useful objects when it comes to
manipulating vectors so let's just for
clarity write out the rules for
multiplying a vector by a matrix so that
sums up exactly what we were doing in
the table here we're multiplying down
the columns and we're summing across the
rows so we've been able to represent
rotation using a matrix format let's now
go on and see if we can represent scale
in the same way so using our rules from
before we can take a vector say 1 1 and
the scale matrix so what we want to do
is scale say in the Y direction so we
want to stay the same in X and multiply
by 2 in Y and then put zeros here so
following our rules for vector matrix
multiplication we can see that the new x
component is 1 times 1 is 1 plus 1 times
0 is 1 1 times 0 is 0 plus 1 times 2 is
2 is that the same answer that we were
getting before so let's just try our
old-fashioned vector vector
multiplication to do a scale on 2 equals
1 times 1 is 1 1 times 2 is 2 it's the
same it's probably a good idea to
explain why we would do it this silly
convoluted way why would we take
something that was very simple before
just adding and multiplying vectors and
then re representing them in this
strange formats in going through these
complicated rules of addition and
multiplication to get the same answer we
have to apply these Tran
formations every single vertex in order
to move these 3d objects around in 3d
space that's really what we're trying to
achieve so with the simple operations
it's fine
but we have to apply them all separately
one after the other and that's okay for
five vertex pyramid but if you've got a
hundred thousand vertices it quickly
becomes quite costly and the more
transformations that you have to apply
at every single vertex the more costly
it becomes and this is where the power
of the matrix lies this format allows us
to actually multiply together two
matrices and by multiplying together two
matrices we get a third matrix which
represents the two transformations that
were encoded in the original two
matrices what we can do is we can
concatenate and combine transformation
after transformation simply by
multiplying matrices together and we can
do that to compute a single
transformation matrix which we then
apply to every single vertex so we don't
have to do transformation of the
transformation after transformation we
can just do one operation a matrix
vector multiply at every vertex let's
have a quick look at the rules for
matrix matrix multiplication and if Xian
has any sense of cut this bit out
because it's really dull
with represented scale we've represented
rotation in matrix form that I said
before can we do translation and the
answer is yes but it's difficult because
of this multiplication everywhere
there's nowhere that we can put our
translation vector because scale and
rotation are multiplicative operations
whereas translation is an additive
operation and we can't do simple ads
with the matrix multiplication rules
everything gets multiplied somewhere
what we really want to do is say
something like this we want to say that
our new vector equals the old vector
times our transformation matrix plus a
translation what we really want to do
ideally is we want to move this
translation into the matrix but there's
nowhere for us to put it because this is
an additive operation and the matrix is
for multiplies the way we do it is using
a little trick instead of just having X
Y we add an extra dimension onto our
vectors and we fill it with one and we
have to do something similar to the
matrix in turn so that the rules can
still be applied so we go a B oops we
then have to have sorry c d e f 0 0 1
and we have to have then a special value
at the bottom here let's just do the
formula for X based on our previous
rules but with the extra rows and
columns added on so yeah let's just
follow along here we've got X a and plus
YB plus 1 times C X D plus y e plus 1
times F and then we've got 1 times 0
plus 1 times 0
plus one
oats plus one times one what we're doing
here is we're multiplying as we were
doing before but we're multiplying by
one so these values C and F remain the
same but they get added on to the
previous result so the net effect is
what we've done is we've found a tricky
way to be able to do addition inside the
matrix which means that we can throw
translation in there now C and F can be
our translation vector and it will be
multiplied by one and added to the
results it seems like a bit of a hack a
bit of a weird trick but what we're
really doing is moving our simple 2d
shape on its 2d plane into the third
dimension so that it exists on a single
plane in 3d space and the special matrix
with the extra row is doing a three
dimensional shear in 3d space but in the
2d space of the plane that looks like a
translation so we've seen how it kind of
works mathematically and what we're
really doing of course is some weird
pan-dimensional trickery because of
course when we're working in 3d we add
an a fourth dimension onto the vectors
and a fourth row and column onto the
matrices and we're doing a shear
operation in four dimensional space
which casts the shadow over of its
objects back into three-dimensional
space as a translation it looks like a
translation in 3d but really it's
mind-blowing
no matter how you arrange the three
vertices of triangle they will always
lie on the same plane in space how not
to store passwords emitted thank you
because you you really shouldn't store
passwords yourself if you can all avoid
it